hey everybody it's Mike from motorflows
and welcome to the last trading day of
the Years December 30th Friday December
30th uh 2022 and you know it was an
interesting day you know we've been we
sold off uh pretty much all night and
into the morning and then we got a rally
going into the close and we settled uh
down
but just slightly it's down like a
quarter of a point but you know this uh
big move down you know a lot of people
have been talking about you know sort of
coming into the last trading day of the
year there was probably going to be
selling anyway because you know people
are trying to lock in their losses to be
written off on their tax bills right the
whole concept of tax harvesting
um so what does 2023 bring well we'll
see I mean you know the FED has sort of
signaled that they're gonna likely wait
until 2024 to cut interest rates but you
know in all honesty that's a long way
away
a lot could happen between uh now and
2024 so you know really I think going
into 20
um you know the FED obviously is
something you're going to keep an eye on
and you know we got earnings coming out
in the middle of January but you know I
want to talk about some of the
interesting order flow that took place
today you know I said cash opened and
you know the market had been under
pressure all night cash opened and you
sort of made new lows bounced up came
back
had a nice little pullback then rallied
uh then obviously sold off again it then
had that big monster rally going into
the close so let's take a look at the
footprint chart so again you know cash
opened and we were already trading at
our lows uh we got a little bit of a
bounce off our lows uh a few minutes
afterwards and again you know there's
not really any strong reason to be
buying at you know right off the cash
open because you know it's the last
trading day of the year it's probably
going to be a very busy day I mean it's
that you know people think all that
Christmas to New Year's is going to be
kind of quiet but you know what today
was is and you get it every year right
it's the last training day of the year
that's one thing it's the quarter end
and it's your end so you're going to
have a lot of people
um taking advantage of you know if they
have losses you know selling it to to
lock in uh potential you know tax
write-off and you know people are just
adjusting their portfolio going into the
new year it's
really a day that you know can be a
trend day but as you saw right the
market did reverse and go back up so you
know what I thought was was really
interesting now again you know sort of
coming into this day we had been selling
off we did get this nice little bounce
here right at 8 33 and it looked like
you know what maybe we go higher right
you see nice positive Deltas
um we got that nice reversal bar right
here but again you know at 8 33 in the
morning right this is the chart here
right selling off all night then you're
gonna say well this Market is oh this is
going to be the low probably not right
cash is just opened again you know
you're coming into Year End Market have
been trending down all night don't
expect the load to be made you know
right away
and you know we kept making new lows
kept making uh a new low here at 8 50.
we did bounce up a bit and then we
started
um you know sort of drifting sideways
most of the morning now what was
interesting is this 3835 area right in
here now on the bar chart let's expand
it up a little bit
38.35 just draw this line right here is
right here okay so because what I'm
going to talk about is you know that the
big volume that's coming in okay so our
low was made here earlier
trading 38.35 shortly after the low went
up came back down traded 38-35 went up
came back down trading 38.35 however
after about 10 30 some big size came in
right in here I don't know if you can
see that let me expand it up a little
bit okay so at 10 21 it traded all the
way down to 34 and a quarter at 10 22
and at a low this bar of 34 and three
quarters
1024 low of 34 and three quarters now
all of a sudden
10 25
10 26 you're seeing a big bid come into
the market right it trades 862. it
trades 9.57 it trades
uh 1274.
excuse me and it trades 19.
sorry about that um got something stuck
in my throat there then it trades 1993.
so you know this volume 862 the 957 the
1274 the 1993 that's over 5 000
contracts a big bid came in there it's
holding this Market from 10 26 to 10.29
now you know everyone that trades on a
dome or a market depth map oh my gosh
there's such big liquidity markets gotta
go up right well it did go up a little
bit but it came down actually once that
liquidity got
um taken out right Market did dip down
to uh 38.33
and three quarters but again it still it
starts it's still hanging around this
3835 okay
what does that mean you know who knows
what that 5000 contracts is you know it
could be
you know again you know somebody
covering a position it could be
something against an option we don't
know all I do know is there was a big
size that came in there didn't really
hold the market and again you got to
look at it in context okay
this was our low of the day here at 8
51.
we rallied up you know up into 3850s and
came back down and again it's kind of
acting as support
okay
then what happens a few bars later right
all of a sudden we see a Five Points
higher this is 38.35 at 38.40
not only do you see this big bid there
25 uh fourteen two and a half thousand
contracts but if this Market just gets
bought up it just basically essentially
gets swept up
um there's about three
this is 2500 this is 942 so I'd say you
know about three and a half thousand
contracts right so basically just got
bit up immediately right someone who was
trading 38 30
38 37 three quarters basically they said
just buy it up to 38.40 they just bought
everything up there right you can see
how do I know that is because there's no
counter trade it's going to say well
isn't this uh a stop
for what
all right someone was
um buying it right here okay if this was
a stop to protect that it would be a
sell stop right because they're long so
basically I and it's five points away
right it's not like uh four and three
quarters you know basically in my
opinion someone's just it's got a lot of
stuff to buy basically right they bought
about five thousand here another three
thousand right here because they bought
everything from 38 all the way up to uh
40. right and they turned it bid
so and then their bid is just basically
holding the market finally it trades out
comes down a little bit but this 3840
then
you know we have the 3835 right here
okay so here's 40 here's 35 it's acting
basically as your support area now I
mean this was a support area but
obviously we're trading much higher a
big bit comes in there you still got to
be aware of these levels right where the
big bids came in to the market
okay so now this 40 area is sort of your
your new level
35 was earlier now it's 40 obviously but
it happened pretty quick and you can see
it's it's holding for the most part
um we do dip a little bit below and we
trade back up into the 45s
um you know in the mid 40s
you know for for quite a while before
the market breaks right and then once we
start to break okay now I know I have a
support I know earlier I had a big buyer
at 40. I know I had a big buyer at 35.
what I want to watch is
are they still there right do they still
have more buying because if I know that
I had a big buying earlier and the
market comes back to that air to that
level it was acting as support earlier
right you saw that right it traded a few
times into it right here and here and I
mean here you can sort of sense that
it's not necessarily there anymore but
the market did jump up anyway so again
I'm not you know I can't say well it's
no longer there because we traded three
ticks through it
um you know I still want to watch it
when it sort of comes back into it on a
more serious level meaning that we had
been a bit higher you know 10 points
higher almost and then start coming down
into that area
and we come back into it
right here 3840 you don't see the volume
right there are some volumes here 318
324.
um but I'm not really seeing anything on
the bins here at this area I mean 187
that's nothing 137 that's nothing
158 that's nothing you even see some
aggressive selling going into that at
this 187 here against 15. sort of goes
sideways breaks down in a few minutes
later comes into that 35 area so I know
that my 40 area didn't hold so I know
that buyers no longer there and again
when you see 8 000 contracts essentially
eight and a half thousand contracts
I'm not looking at it in the sense of oh
this is a day trader they've gonna you
know they're gonna have a stop in here
somewhere to get out of it no this is
probably somebody that's again either
doing this against some other position
or maybe they got a much longer term
view maybe they think the Market's going
to go up in the new year
um you know whatever but it my point is
it's more of um
you know other time frame Trader right
other time frame money long-term money
right it's and they're just not gonna
immediately reverse if it goes five
points against them right because you
know basically they're the average
between 40 and 35 is like what 37 and a
half I don't think they're going to have
a stop down here at at 32 to get out
because that's not how they trade right
they got Deep Pockets they're probably
going to be holding it for a while if
it's a new position if it's getting out
of something or or hedge against
something then I'm not expecting any
immediate
um
stop loss you know thrown in the market
to get out
you know because again you know I know
people that trade
and their view is sort of you know I
mean like scalpers right you know
everybody is is a cell right anytime
someone gets long they gotta start
looking at the exit well long-term
Traders they don't think in that way
right they're more of the uh
the thin Aykroyd type on
trading places where you're sitting
there pork bellies right any other takes
a view that's how long term Traders
macro guys have that sort of view they
say okay I'm ready to get in Boom by
five thousand boom buy another 3 000.
um they're not immediately sweating it
out thinking you know I just paid 37 and
a half as average if we break down to 30
I'm out no you know they're going to be
holding it for the duration
as long as they can so
I know that buying is not there and if I
know that I and imagine it was just 5
000 contracts at 35. now you're coming
back into that area you don't see that
sort of buying I'm looking for the
market to blow right through and it did
it just blew right through here pretty
easily
from 35 all the way down into you know
the low 20s
um we're sort of made this low and it's
starting to come back up right it broke
through pretty quick you know you're
talking that was 12 21 to
you know 12 27 so about six minutes
right from breaking that at 35 down to
you know basically 21 and a half but you
know
10 points in a matter of one two three
four five
six minutes okay
now it starts coming back up right and
again you know on this move back up
you're starting to see some nice
aggressive buying obviously the the
Stacked and balance here the imbalance
is spread out in this bar the buying
imbalances here you got some nice
positive Deltas you know nice strong
Delta going into the low which you
expect to see minus 1100 then you got a
nice strong positive Delta plus 1200
okay I like to see that right I mean
that's what you want to see if you're
coming into a Lowe's
um sort of some blow off Delta to the
negative side going into the low which
is what that 1100 is and then
people realize hey you know what this is
cheap let's get in
everyone's coming out of the woodwork to
buy it you know you can see the
aggressive trading coming in and the
market starts rallying right it starts
rallying back up to that 35 area then it
starts hanging around here again now
this was interesting 38 30.
Okay so
came down down down hit the low 21 and a
half started rallying back up
so he hit 30 on the way down 30 on the
back up on the move back up and then
afterwards they're starting to see again
some more support coming in here okay it
hits 30
right here at 12 48 12 49 but just
straight Smalls uh six threes seven then
you see the 398 the 692 the 951 so you
already got you know 2 000 being traded
on the bid here so you got support
coming into the market here 38.30
what's interesting look at these numbers
where are these bids coming in 30 35 40.
hmm right talk about uh
nice
I'll say even numbers but
um you know nice round numbers every
five points you got you're seeing
support come in
so again this was about you know 400 700
900 about 2 000 another thousand ten
forty five so about three thousand right
here at 38.30 okay
600 1800
so again you're looking at you know over
five thousand contracts now again you
know
people that stare at a dome all day or
or look at a heat map they see this
liquidity in there oh the Market's going
to Rally off this but and then they get
they start to get long and
while this trade did work out
what happens is it broke down first
right once it cleared out all that
liquidity there it traded lower right
and I think that's one of the things
that that frustrates people when they're
new to trading on a dome or looking at a
heat map is thinking
5 000 contracts this Market's got to
hold
well no once that five thousand
contracts is that liquidity is removed
from the market Mark's gonna do whatever
it wants there's still some selling
pressure in there Market did drop
um from 30 8 30 you know all the way
back down to uh what was it here
I don't know that's 23 then it starts
coming back up you know before it starts
making that big move so you know the
short-term Traders okay and that's the
difference between short-term Traders
and long-term Traders right other time
frame traders meaning everybody else
besides intraday retail Traders or prop
Traders
the long-term Traders they're they're
happy right their average now is about
38 35
on how many 10 000 contracts 12 000
contracts
you know they're defined to let the
market
go down a little bit I mean you know
again their view of the market is much
longer term than yours in mind but if
you're buying it here by looking at
the liquidity in the market they can all
you know there's a big bid in here I got
to get long
well you're gonna get stopped out
okay
I mean sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't and that that's the whole point
of trading you know some you know
there's nothing that's a hundred percent
it's nothing that's 95 percent
so again you know if you're buying it
there
you know okay you know honestly I me a
lot of times I've taken that shot I've
bought it looking for this rally did you
get a rally 30 up to how high did it get
up to 32 and a half so maybe you could
have scalped out a couple of points you
know maybe up to two or something but
again it's one of those things where is
it going to hold or not you know and
you're trying to scalp out two points
but then you're stopped out for two
points or a point pretty quick again you
know again it's different style of
trading but um you know anyway I guess
my point is don't be seduced by seeing
you know these big bids in the market
thinking uh you got to jump in front
because that's sort of the human nature
right you see a big buyer stepping in
so like what's going on in the UK with
that power water or whatever it is you
know everyone's buying it you know and
see old men buying it at the store from
you know little kids to Old Men
everyone's rushing to buy it because of
whatever same thing right you see big
buyers is coming into the market don't
think oh I gotta buy it I gotta buy it
right still you know understand what's
happening in the order flow
um
then we get that big rally going up you
know going into the close what was
interesting in the order flow going into
this rally once it started once it got
above 38.40 you know it was interesting
because if you're watching these levels
right the 30 level once we got back
above it we quickly got back above 35.
and once we got above 35 hit 40 it just
took off right here's
let's move this up to the the 40 area
This is 40 right here so you know once
we got
you know we the 30 the buyers at 30
you know down here came down
went back above 30 went back above 35
hit 40 jumped up came back down tested
40. you see those little wicks in there
in the candles and then it just you know
took that nice vertical move up all the
way from 40 all the way up above 60.
pretty quick going into the the close
here and this was that first move up
you're seeing the aggressive buying in
here but again you're not really seeing
like big standout volume coming in on
the bids anywhere top of this bar some
nice bids here 794 1300
um
but on this last move up I think it was
around 10 minutes before the close you
start seeing
you know some big bids coming in here
1500 you know the 700
and here's another 1100 you know 1200 so
you're seeing you know people sort of
really coming out in force to mine so
that person that bought you know the 35s
the 40s even the 30s
they're sitting pretty right now right
but they got a longer term view than you
and I and they're able to hold it longer
and that's the difference between the
different types of Traders you know
sometimes people lose track of that
right they lose track of
um
that there are other you know people
that got different long-term views of
the market that that we don't have so
what we can do as individual Traders is
sort of just sort of jump on the back of
it
okay so you know again this is uh the
last trading day of the year December
30th
you know I'll try to get some more
videos up over the over the New Year's
holiday schedule permitting so guys
again I hope you enjoy these videos you
know be sure to like the video and hit
subscribe you know that's what keeps me
um you know wanting to make these videos
for you so have a great uh rest of the
year if I don't make another video and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye bye